all right so it's been an absolutely
insane week in the world of League of
Legends the free agency period started
on Monday and it has been crazy from
Sven to c9 genji completely blowing up
the roster and creating a super team and
sneaky not playing for the only team
he's ever known there's a lot to cover
so let's break it down region by region
let's start with objectively the worst
region by a lot North America obviously
we wash yet another crash and burn at
Worlds for na this year after liquids
crazy run regionally so as usual a lot
of North American teams are looking to
make the big name moves that can make
them relevant internationally so far in
free agency maybe one of the biggest
moves in North America crumbs from cloud
nine we're sneaky is out of the bot lane
entirely and they brought in van from
TSM or b5 TSM definitely needed to go
their way a knock up on the hoody he's
gonna put this thing forward there's the
old a thermos depression there's a lot
of space built by smoothie that's the
one for one so far - it's gonna be a
trade now it's a four sorry three risk -
on the fight to find it cutting away
broken play get the healing the
re-engage
cuatro will it be l5
there's a lot of rumors swirling around
about where Sneaky's gonna end up next
some people think he's gonna stream for
the entire year or sign with another
roster but you have to imagine that the
asking price for a guy like that is
massively hot like I said this Venn has
come in from TSM to replace sneaky maybe
you can start a new any journey with
cloud 9 last bit on cloud 9 suspense
care and their MVP jungler and zeizel
their support are both off - eg alright
so now over to team liquid who made a
big splash of their own fanatics
European jungler Brock's ax is on the
move to North America to take X mythos
walk in the jungle I've got a really
important announcement for you so the
rumors about Broxton and me disliking
each other and having a poor
relationship it just needs to stop a
world where Team Liquid and brock's ax
aren't on the same team just simply
doesn't exist so welcome to the - you -
me going out and getting a star European
player like this shows that liquid is
willing to do whatever it takes to be
relevant on the world stage next year
other notable moves in na include media
signing with 100 thieves bang leaving a
hundred thieves for eg and bio frost and
smoothie swapping spawns alright that's
enough of the trash regions let's move
on to something that matters the lck
where we've seen some of the biggest
best players in the world swap places
over the last few days I think
unquestionably the biggest story out of
Korea the last week is the crazy roster
that Genji has put together in just a
couple days Genji have signed BD d to be
their mid laner cleared it in their
jungle and have added rascal to their
takling they'll join ruler and life in
what was already a star power
the ruler is still alive in the back
line unbelievably splashing foam and he
kills Toby he's looking for more and
she's gonna go up to labor here now it
goes back Ripple there's the Quadra and
it looks like 50 aren't gonna win Game
one rule has done it on the baby managed
it against the cop that was so tricky to
do this almost overnight gives Genji the
potential to compete for an lck title
next in addition to Genji SKT or i guess
now we call them t1 have also made some
big move so far they announced that they
brought in coz from Dragon X to fill the
huge gap left by Clinton there are still
some questions about SKT looking forward
though their legendary coach kkoma still
hasn't resigned with the team and cons
contract is also up in the air so we
expect this team to be a contender next
year but we certainly haven't heard the
last of SKT news this offseason in all
honesty the lck is a bit of a [ __ ] show
right now both dragon X and K T have
completely blown up their rosters and
there is a ton of star power out there
and available for anyone to pick up even
pinna a huge star has left the country
and joined LGD in China speaking of
China let's head there now and get into
their free agency as far as China goes
the roster moves have been pretty tamed
so far the region that has won
back-to-back world titles look like
they're trying to keep everything mostly
the same this year that said there have
been a few key moves that we want to
highlight for you probably the biggest
news out of China so far is that
Invictus gaming z' ad carry Jacky love
is a free agent now we don't know if
that means he's going somewhere else or
he's just looking to negotiate his
contract but he is the biggest name by a
lot that's available and the colonel
knows it as well 84% fleet chance to IG
here we go it's like good chicken here
for the side they jump on it immediately
checking up take superb the second goes
over to him as well it seems like to the
party don't just give it all as IG run
on in they say hey it doesn't matter
Quadra yeah you know he gets the Penta
kill and that'll be all zeroes other
notable news out of China
WEC a and mystic are both free agents
and lastly
Sunan gaming's maple there
highly-touted mid laner is reportedly
leaving the team all right before we
move on I got to tell you about my boy
in when I first started at the score
eSports when I was just a data entry
specialist imp was my favorite player to
watch play League of Legends and after
all these years he's retiring from LPL
play alright so before we move on to
Europe let's all pour 104 empty air
no way
[Music]
all right now let's end things off with
Europe maybe most notably it was just
announced that self-made is going to
fnatic to replace Roxas spot in their
jungle then we have origin who have
completely revamped their lineup over
the last few days they've added zerks a
upset and destiny to completely facelift
their team upset is a young player with
a ton of potential and this could be a
huge pickup for origin in the coming
years
other notable news out of the LEC this
week Gazoo K announced that he's a free
agent on summer has left misfits for
rogue and promised q as left g2 also to
finish up the little bit of news at a
year after we had a retirement visit cha
Chi has played his last game in the LEC
all right so it's been a pretty crazy
first week of the off season in the
league of legends na has players moving
everywhere and all of this Korean
firepower is just up for grabs so if
there's another massive roster move you
can expect to hear from us other news
out of China Xi a and mystic are both
free agents on W e thank you for Ann's
name maple and soon in gaming's man I
keep forgetting his name ba and mystic
are both free agents and soon and gamely
other new other notable news out of
China
other notable news out of China w ease